how are you doing today sir
i'm doing fantastic i'm in my new house
you can't see but it got a beautiful
view and i have a pool behind me and
and i'm divorced so here i am
i uh i didn't know and i'm gonna say
sorry um no don't no say thank you and
congratulations
and that's good uh thank you and
congratulations
um i was gonna say that i was lucky
enough to visit your old place and
uh and uh uh i i like that house it was
cool
yeah it was cool but uh this this one is
all one level which i love mid-century
um because i'm a bit of a uh a neophyte
architect buff
and uh it's got everything i need and my
kids need and i'm away from all the
craziness
i i didn't mention i was divorced you
did
i single i'm single for the first time
since i'm 25
since i'm 24 years old um
yeah i i never ask people about personal
life stuff so
i won't dig down on this i will just say
if you're happy then i'm happy for you
i love you right um all right let's jump
into why
into my list of questions because i got
a lot you've acted in a number of
different projects and you've been on a
number of different tv things
is there a tv series you would love to
guest star on
yes staron uh i think maybe peaky
blinders
i think that's really well done and it's
cool i like cool tv shows
um uh you know this is why i love doing
kingdom because i felt like that was a
show i would watch
um so yeah i think i think something
like pinky piggy blinders or maybe
mandalorian
i could i could definitely see you on
mandalorian and and piggy blinders
but both would be a good fits for you be
fun yeah i'm trying to find a good tv
show
either to develop a show uh with
carnahan
or or maybe find something you know that
is either limited or
or you know like kingdom was 10 episodes
season you know
uh i love i love doing really good tv
it's it's uh it's fun
and it's it pays well sure also tv's
never been better than it is right now
it's that tv is where it's at yep nope
no completely um you you i looked at
your schedule i looked at what you've
been filming recently
and i have to ask do you take time off
if i can i do for a very short amount of
time i don't like sitting around
and um you know i
i just love to work i like to be doing
something you know like i
you know i always say like if you're a
musician you play music all the time
if you're a painter you're painting all
the time if you're a plumber you're
usually plumbing all the time it's like
i don't get where actors want to
sit around and you know kind of wait for
the perfect job
you know i listen if if it checks off
two or three boxes out of ten
for me i'm gonna do it you know um
speaking of painting uh so i watch
billions
and i'm a big fan of that show you
played a
painter in the recent season which aired
half the season already
um yeah are you in the back half of the
episodes i think i'm only in one or two
uh which was the plan before we shut
down so i think there's one or two
left that i'm i'm obligated to do uh
and they're a great group of guys and
ladies and uh
it was a lot of fun so i'm look i'm
actually looking forward to going and
kind of closing it out
right and that's the thing like so when
they wrapped on the first half of the
episodes
so they haven't filmed yet the second
half no they they you know
look we that was when new york got hit
with covet but right in the beginning
and i was staying at a hotel that
actually shut down like the day after
i left so it had gotten really serious
then
and uh you know i think i'm going back
sometime in march
uh got it did you yeah listen i love i
love billions i think the acting and the
writing
it's just a really fun show
were you familiar with it prior to doing
your guest role
i made myself a bit familiar with it i
don't i don't
because i'm moving around a lot i don't
watch a lot of things
i'm friends with giamatti i've been
friends with giamatti for 15 years
um and and i knew he was on the show
i've seen it a few times
i didn't realize how popular the show
was it's very very popular
was it one of those things that after
your episode started airing all of a
sudden
people are coming up to you and being
like oh my god i loved you on billions
yeah um they would be like hey man i saw
you on billions and he's
like i love you at this point in my life
like it's it's and it's flattering but
you know
wherever i go like there's people know
who i am it's you know
you know yeah there's the different
levels of fame so i'm somewhere in the
middle
but when when i start getting like 60
year old women
coming up to me and saying oh my god i
love you and you're the great you're the
artist
and i'm like you know that's not my
demographic so it's like oh this is
interesting
like people who i normally wouldn't be
you know would never see me do what i do
are now tuning in and look you you
realize the power of television
and i was only on the show for what
seven or eight episodes i mean
then it started to pour in like people
really love me i'm doing so i'm like oh
i gotta watch this i gotta see how i was
and uh it's you know it's like you said
it's a great show with great people and
and uh you know i'm so dumb i think uh
who's gonna see that you know so it's
good you can
you can gain an audience even at my old
age well what's interesting is what a
lot of people i think sometimes forget
is when you're on a show like that that
a lot of people
are watching or a lot of industry people
are watching
all of a sudden it's like casting agents
you're on casting agents radars that you
might normally not be on their radar
yeah i mean you know look i do a certain
thing you know i play a certain kind of
character mostly there's a there's a
of a variance you know on on that
character but mostly
it's that guy and you know when people
see me do
different things like that it's why i do
these little movies like it's why i do
this movie no man's land or i got a
movie coming after that body brokers
they're little movies that i get to be
something other than what people really
know me for
and you know to not only catheters
mostly you know i mean i i
it's producers who then call and go hey
would you be interested in doing that
and i'm like yeah man let's let's talk
um you've been acting for at least 20
years i believe
um no 30 years
yeah 30 years 30 years 30 years it's
very hard to be
earning a living as a working actor
where that is um
all you're doing and get you know
earning a living and you were lucky
enough to break
to to be in that boat now where you know
this is all you do
when did you first realize that you had
made it as
like an actor and that you could do this
full-time my first full-time gig
on guiding light 100 years ago
you know i made a lot of money i mean i
was a kid i was well i was in my late
20s and i was on a soap opera
full time and i was like i never i never
that was it
i never turned back i mean you know i i
knew i didn't want to stay in a soap
opera
but i kept i just never stopped i've had
some dry spells a couple months here a
couple months there
scary but um i'm i'm i'm a real working
actor like i
never stopped working from then on and
uh you know i i don't really
i don't i don't worry about it i don't
worry about
now i get offers all the time and it's
it's great you know i'm grateful i kind
of carved out a niche for myself
but i i just always figured this is what
i'm gonna do
and uh i'm gonna live within my means
and then just keep working you know and
i got so many friends that said well i
want to try to be this kind of actor i'm
like i'm
just going to try to be a working actor
because i also need to
feed my family you know like people say
to me why would you do that piece of
[ __ ] movie jiu jitsu
and i'm like well the truth is they paid
me a lot of money
and i went to greece for five days
and it was a lot of money it was
probably more money than most people
work
make in five years maybe ten years
and i was like okay i'm gonna go i'm
gonna do my thing i'm gonna be as quiet
as i can
and i'm gonna leave and i'm gonna go to
the bank so you know guys like me
and i get a lot of [ __ ] for some of
these shitty movies i've been in i'm
like well they paid me
that's you know i'm not i'm not george
clooney like nobody's paying me 15
million dollars to do something and then
i could wait another two years to do
something else
and uh and so it's worked for me you
know it's i know
when i'm doing some things they're not
going to be good and they're going to be
a little cheesy
and i'm like as long as i do my work and
i come out of it clean
i'll be okay but what's interesting is
you were
in a movie that most americans don't
know which i believe is wolf warrior 2
which is like one of the highest
grossing if not the highest grossing
movie in china
oh no it's in china it'll never be
surpassed it's made a billion dollars in
china it'll not
it's the big by far the biggest movie
ever the chinese domestic release by far
right so my thing is that i think a lot
of people don't realize listen obviously
when you signed on to that you had no
idea what that movie was going to be
and but also like china is now
or it's going to be one of the biggest
movie audiences in the world if it's not
already there
so how does wolf warrior 2 being in that
are all of a sudden you're getting more
offers from movies that are being done
in china because everyone knows who you
are
well i am you know i am a name in china
a big name in china because of that
movie and so
uh you know it's not like i'm getting a
lot of
offers in china it's if
if there are if there are movies that
are being made
and it's a chinese producer or chinese
financier
my name is always my name's always there
always there
because i have that kind of value in
china you know by happenstance
um i never thought this would have you
know i never thought when i came back
from
from doing that movie or when the movie
came out and it made a billion dollars
every studio head wanted to sit down
with me like i like i did this like i
planned it out
you know what i mean i'm like i don't i
don't you know i don't know
and then and then cover it happens but
um yeah i mean
listen i'm in that movie then i'm in
the marvel movies from the captain
america movies that
they're huge in china huge it's why i
got that movie it's why they offered me
that movie
and and you know and then the purge
franchises all over the world
even kingdom is all over the world um
so so a guy like me an actor the way
movies get financed
is through foreign value so i have far
more value
in other parts of the world than i do in
the united states so from for
guys making independent films i'm good
because they can raise money before they
even start shooting film
from the different nations and
territories that i can bring money into
now some guys bring in a lot of money
and some guys can bring in some money
so those are the movies there you go
that's the career that you
you kind of try to eke out you know what
i mean
sure listen i i respect what you do i
think a lot of people
uh dream about just being a working
actor
and and the fact that anyone this
industry is
and i think a lot of people don't
realize how difficult it is
to make it as an actor to be a working
actor
and any yeah any person who is a working
actor and then make a living at it
[ __ ] you've won the lottery yeah if
you're just to work let you know and
look
i've had my share of wows right like
even just you know driving down i
remember when me and mackie did point
blank i'm driving down sunset boulevard
and there's
my face and my me and mac you're on a
poster on sunset blue i'm like wow
i mean who could have ever imagined like
you know even now i still get surprised
by
all of the movie offers that i get on a
weekly basis you know and
i'm like wow i remember struggling for
auditions and now i get all these movie
offers and a lot of them i can't take
they're low-hanging fruit
and it's probably not good for my career
um regardless of money
but it's still i still at this point in
my life i'm like
this is amazing like this is you know i
could take a breath and relax a little
bit
because i've been running for 30 years
you know um
so yeah it is and i i don't poo poo
any actor for doing anything ever if
you're working
you're in this business you've you've
won the you've won the lottery
they're doing a what if uh animated
series for marvel
uh which is like you know um did they
ask you to do anything
yeah no i'm in it i've i've been doing
it okay so that's what i wanted to know
um yeah what what when they presented
that to you was it one of these things
how early on did you know
that like how early on did they ask you
to do it and is it one of these things
where you sort of trust marvel
implicitly and you're like okay whatever
you need i'm doing it yeah
look look it's like you know if the
president calls and says i want you to
come to the white house you don't ask
why you just kind of get on a plane and
go to the white house
when marvel you know ca called my agents
called and said they're doing this thing
what if and this
they have uh four or five episodes
planned out you can do it all and
i'm like whatever whatever i don't i
don't care what the money it doesn't
matter yes i'm going to do it absolutely
all day every day got it uh
did you record everything in one day
those four or five episodes i recorded
in
one day or two days and now
uh i think i have to go in february to
record a few more
i loved the what if comic when i was
growing up loved
um how familiar are you or were you with
the what if comics
and when you're recording how much are
they showing you
on a screen in terms of like the
animatics or like what it's going to
look like and how much is it just sort
of you're reading off the page
you're just kind of interpreting it
yourself and reading off the page and
trying to stay into the character of
crossbones and they set up the scenario
and uh and we just kind of play around
and uh until we get it
and and it's uh and then they show a
little bit sometimes but you know marvel
they don't want to show you too much
because
especially me i'm a big mouth and they
i've been scolded
many times i don't think you're gonna
get scolded any more
than uh ruffalo for live streaming on
his phone
right you know i think that's gonna
ultimately be the top of
the [ __ ] up list yeah but even right you
know look cheeto ruffalo all those guys
they're all such great guys they really
are but that you know they panic you
know when they get in trouble
you know they they they panic because
marvel
marvel is is the universe i mean you
know you don't want to [ __ ] around
kevin feige oh no he i believe
believe me he he has um more uh let's
just say he's kind of powerful
i think he's probably the most powerful
guy in town
i really do i know he's now he's now
he's hot now he's taking over the star
wars things and
and for disney i mean he's he's the god
man he's the guy and by the way
a phenomenal guy phenomenal guy humble
completely the thing any the thing that
i think a lot of people don't realize
and and i've interviewed him for like 12
years now
is that he's the same guy from 12 years
ago that he is
now this success has not gone to his
head he's
it's just it's so the anomaly uh
out of the people that i've encountered
in hollywood it's it's that but that's
the reason why kevin feige's kevin feige
and you know what i've never heard a bad
word about like no one
this is a town where they love to see
you get to the top but really they love
to crush you when you when you're
falling off the
mountain i've never heard anybody say a
bad word about him
do you know like he's a good dude he's a
smart guy
uh who loves what he does and he does it
better than anyone else
and you know god bless him i mean you
know kevin feige changed
changed the world he really did he
changed the world
he with the movies that he and people
will argue oh you know
the marvel movies have [ __ ] up the
movie business and they vampirize it i'm
like
no they created the movie business the
movie business that was dying
they have saved the movie business yeah
uh listen the the
the superhero genre are you a bit
surprised because listen you obviously
were in a number of marvel movies
are you a bit surprised at the the
lasting popularity of the superhero
genre because
oh you oh i don't you got to remember
crossbones was on screen for like
17 minutes or 12 minutes whatever it is
i mean the first one when it was brock
rumlow i was in the whole movie
basically but
i was brock rumba who nobody cared this
is how you know the power of marvel i'm
in the movie for
12 minutes the way
and more than anything people like
crossbones we love crossbones i'm like
crossbows was barely in the movie like
he had a couple of fights and that was
then he was blown up it's like
but the power of of marvel is such that
they don't realize it's 12 minutes the
audience all they know is
he's one of the guys he's one of the
characters that they love or love to
hate
and that's the that's the zeitgeist
that's the power
that that these movies have and the
weight that they carry it's it's fun
i am amazed by it i don't want to get
you in trouble about the what if um
i don't know much more i don't like i
really don't
it just kind of popped back up i
recorded that like probably almost a
year ago
and you know i'm sure with covert and
everything everything was put on hold
uh but now it's come back around and i
literally don't know anything more about
it than i just
you know i don't even remember what i
was doing i don't even remember what i
said
in when i end the shows but i think it's
going to be my
my little guy my son rio is not so
little he's 13.
uh i mean he's a crazy marvel he can't
wait to see it he can't wait
yeah i've seen some of the animation um
and it looks really cool then again
i have a lot of faith that marvel's
going to um
you know deliver jumping into the next
thing um you've done a lot of stunts
when you think back on all the stunts
you've done which is the one that before
you did it you were like
oh i don't know about this one we were
doing uh cap two
winter soldier and we were out in long
beach on a
aircraft carrier so however many stories
above sea level
the the boat is which is i mean it's so
it's like 150 feet up
right there was a crane on the deck
which was another 150 feet up so you
were probably 300 feet up from the
from the water and basically we had to
do is clip into the crane
and and and they they dropped us so that
it looked like we were flying onto the
boat
and i wasn't gonna do it i said i'm not
doing that let my let my guy do it i'm
not doing it
and scarlett johansson said well i'm
doing it
yep so she went and did it and then i
had to do it
i think in the movie i fly in behind her
and uh
she didn't but i had [ __ ] in my pants
because i was that afraid
yeah and it was pitch black it was
nighttime
right so i i i first of all
i could never do that and second of all
but what i ca i can only imagine what
it's like on set when scarlett says
she's going to do it
scarlett i mean it's like you know okay
scarlet i guess i guess i'm going to do
it too
you know um the only other thing i did
uh that i that was stupid is and it
wasn't a stunt
but when i when i did uh the movie the
david air movie with gyllenhaal and pena
yeah we were the uh gyllenhaal had this
great idea that he was gonna get tased
so he could feel what it was feeling
like
and i'm like i'm not doing that you're
stupid and then natalie martinez
beautiful natalie martinez said well i'm
gonna do it and i'm like
mother now i gotta do it
because i'm you know that guy and it was
miserable
yeah so yes mostly i just fight you know
mostly i'll do all my own fighting i'll
do my own driving
as long as i'm not driving off something
i try not to jump too much
i don't i don't like jumping off things
jumping into why i actually get to talk
to you today which is no man's land
um what was it talk for people that
aren't familiar with the project
talk a little bit about what it's about
and who you play yeah i mean uh you know
this is one of those movies where i'm
like okay i get to do something
different it's a serious movie
and you know there's a strip of land
called no man's land it's
it you know borders texas and and
uh and it's basically the land between
two fences
that if you're uh if you're a us citizen
you have to carry your passport
and it you know it's it's not america
really
and it's not mexico and so they call it
no man's land and some people's houses
have gotten stuck
in the middle of this by no design of
their own but because of the government
and how they they set up these fences
and i play a you know a texas rancher
who is uh
you know fighting off all of these what
they call coyotes these these drug
runners coming in from mexico
and uh you know unfortunately there's a
lot of innocent people just trying to
find a better life here
and something happens and and uh a kid
gets killed
and my son is uh is the one who shot
shot the gun
and and we it turns into a chase movie
he runs into mexico
and myself and andy mcdowell plays my
wife you know we have to deal with
getting him back
and dealing with the issues that have
become so serious
in this no man's land between mexicans
and and americans and you
basically learn at the end you go
through a journey and
you start to feel what it's like to be
on the american side but you feel again
what these mexicans go through
on the daily and i thought what it what
a timely and important
these are two young filmmakers uh
connor and jake allen and i'm like i'm
in man i you know that's the kind of
things i could go and do for a few weeks
and i don't expect anything from it i'm
not really getting paid anything
um and it's i think it's something that
that is important
uh so i'm excited i think i think people
have received it fairly well
and uh i'm excited for the these guys
because it was their first film and they
decided to do something really
really serious when you are getting
ready to do a film like that uh you're
riding
obviously you're on horseback in the
film and you know it's dealing with
real life stuff how much are you
actually
researching what's going on in the area
trying to take in as much information as
you can
even if it's not stuff that maybe will
apply to
um you know like maybe it's just for
your subconscious to be able to
you know use in the scene it's mostly
for that so mostly most of the research
is to create behavior
so it has nothing to do with what i'm
saying or even what you may know even if
you're the director
i just have to fill myself with enough
of of the circumstance
that my behavior is going to be
authentic right
i'm going to act like this guy and i did
i did a lot of research and a lot of
reading about
a lot of families that have been caught
up in this in this
no man's land which i knew nothing about
i'm so ignorant
uh and and it was you know look and both
sides had really good
valid points they really didn't you know
at the end it's just people trying to
make a better life for themselves and
for their families
that's really the crux to the whole
thing they just want a better life for
their families
and and so in the end we can all relate
to that
do you know what i mean and and my my
struggles
there's a there's you know there should
be people should be empathic towards
even though i'm kind of the antagonist
you should be empathic towards me
because in the end i realize that
their struggles are my struggles and so
we're in this together kind of thing
does that make sense no completely it's
interesting because i just watched
another movie uh the marksman which is a
liam neeson film
because i'm talking to him on monday and
his movie
takes place essentially around no man's
land okay so
it's really i was like watching it i'm
like wait a minute this is weird how two
films are
you know it uh not that he's in no man's
land but it's right on the border his
house
he's dealing with no i know i know a bit
about it because the guys raven the guys
who made that movie
are the producers who i just worked with
on cop shop me and joe they produced a
movie for us they financed the movie
so we're very good friends with them and
the marksman is like their big movie
that's
that's coming out before cop shop uh so
i know a bit about it and there are some
similarities there and you know i'm
great friends when you when you talk to
liam tell them
tell them i said i said hello i actually
owe him a phone call but uh
he's i love him he's great i'm sure the
movie's gonna be fantastic and it's
it's good to see liam doing serious
things what's interesting about liam
is that he is just one of those guys and
i'm sure
maybe you i'm sure you agree with me
that i could i could watch him do just
about anything on screen and i'm gonna
find it interesting
and i love seeing him punch people in
the face
yeah and you know he's look he's a big
he's six foot six
six foot five he's he's an artist he's a
poet
he's a boxer and he's kind of like
he's kind of like teflon when it comes
to
the movies that he chooses i mean he's
been in some movies that have not been
great but he's really great and
he gets a pass like he's because he's
always he's watching he's always
watchable always you always want to
watch the guy
you know listen i've been around movie
stars
and there's a couple of them that even
around other movie stars
they shine right liam's one of those
guys like i come in rooms with liam
neeson and it's like
when men and women fall down it's
ridiculous the other guy's mel gibson
you can be in rooms with movie stars and
you come in with mel and they're like oh
it's mel gibson
so it's really interesting like some
guys are just
in the stratosphere as far as that
um you mentioned cop chop which is
something i was going to address anyway
tell people because i know you just
wrapped on that not too long ago for
people that aren't familiar
uh what is it about and you know it's
you and carnahan's next
film after boss level yeah so carnahan
uh rewrote it and basically
it is i i play a fixer in vegas
uh that that deals with the politicians
and the mob and
uh i i have to turn state's evidence and
uh so as they're transporting me they
try to assassinate me
and i get away and in order for me to be
safe so i can figure out what to do uh
i'm in vegas i punch a cop
in the face so that they'll take me to
jail and they bring me to the jail
gerard butler is the guy chasing me he
sees what happens
he gets himself put in jail and the
first two acts of the movie take place
in the cop shop in the jail cell uh
and then the third act turns into a
full-blown shoot-em-out action movie
so it's it's i it's shot beautifully
it is it is kooky i have long hair i
i it's a real character piece for me
butler is great knit
it's a real kind of cat and mouse thing
in the beginning of the film and then
the third lead in the movie uh alexis
louder is a young african-american
actress who is going to be a star and
she's the cop that i punch in the face
and we we have this relationship and she
has a relationship with butler she
doesn't know who to trust and she trusts
the wrong one
and that's how the whole thing turns
into a [ __ ] show in the third act but
it's a really cool
very d it's much like boss level it kind
of mashes genres together
and it's it's very singular and in what
it is
yeah it's interesting we you talked
earlier about foreign sales and the
importance of certain actors
gerard butler is one of those guys that
yeah
he he's on with international stuff
bigger than anybody any movie gets made
if butler's in it talk a little bit
about putting this thing together
and landing gerard in it well i we know
drew i know gerard the script came with
gerard
semi attached right and i called jerry
and i was like are you still attached to
this he goes
i don't know he goes you know i got
other things happening i said well
carnahan's gonna do a pass i wanna show
it to you after
he read it he was like i you know i
don't know i said okay so we're gonna go
out to somebody else we actually went
out to liam
we went out to liam and we talked to
liam we gave it to liam
and he said you know it's very close to
another movie
uh in the sense that it takes it's very
it's very uh
inside one building whatever it was liam
passed
we went back to jerry and uh
jerry ultimately for whatever reason
that's not important he said yes
and uh you know the reality is when
you're a financier like raven
names like liam neeson and jerry butler
are the names that can get you the most
money so that
you don't really need a whole lot of
equity when you're making the movie
because the foreign territories have
already pre-sold
and you kind of make the movie with that
money and those two guys
are the biggest names right now globally
for international finance when do you
think people are going to see a trailer
or footage or stuff from it i think
what we're trying to do is put some kind
of a sizzle trailer together
coinciding with when um boss level drops
got it i want to jump into boss level
which is
um we did essentially a world premiere
screening
at arclight hollywood almost a year ago
now
and it was like one of the last things
that we did as part of our screening
series
um i'm so excited for people to finally
see this movie because it kicked
so much ass for you what has it been
like having like
this is a really really fun cool
movie that you've been waiting for
people to see for like a year and
something what is this billions
yeah you know look it was it's that
movie that really could be a game
changer for me
it could be a game changer for for war
party for our company
and you know we've had to sit back and
deal with a lot of obstacles
throughout the two years almost and then
covet came
and you know not unlike many other films
we found a streamer and hulu that
really saw the value in the film
especially what's going on now it's good
to have a movie that's just fun
we are so lucky and fortunate that hulu
came
with a with a life raft and and kind of
saved us
uh from this whole covered thing yeah i
think i think the movie's gonna do
tremendous on hulu mostly because the
movie kicks ass
yeah and you know and there's not it's
coming out at the right time because
there's not a lot of
um movies are obviously in pause mode
right now because there's not a lot of
product coming out
because you know well there's some you
know what i mean yeah
and you know look the studio system and
which i'm really not part of but the
studio system and
and those people who release movies
theatrically big movies
you know there was so much trepidation
to go
back to who used to be their rivals last
year and those are the streamers
and then have to do business with them
because it's the only way to to get to
get these movies sold and out
and i think you know we thought oh in
six months it'll be okay and theaters
will open and then another three months
we think maybe they'll open
it's you know in la it's just
it's not opening anytime soon i mean la
is a [ __ ] show we covered
so what do you do you know what do you
do like france
they closed their theaters again new
york's closed their fear
it's like how much time could go by
before you got to get these movies out
because you got other movies you got to
make
it's the only way we could keep the
industry alive do you know
um so here we are look we i think we
lucked i think we lucked out i really do
march 5th so we're right around the
corner i think the timing for the movie
is
perfect uh a few more questions uh
i really enjoyed the hitman's bodyguard
um i had fun with because it's just ryan
and sam yelling at each other
you're you're in the sequel um what can
you say about who you play
and you know making the sequel so i play
a um an interpol agent from boston
who does not want to be in europe and uh
i'm forced to go there to kind of
wrangle up the guys
and and and the girls uh and to
and to uh kind of force them to help me
bust this ring in europe and
it's a great cast but banderas is in it
uh uh
obviously sam and selma and and ryan and
and uh there's a bunch of other great
people and it's basically a you know a a
cat and mouse
you know it's a chase film throughout
italy and croatia
and and france and the united states
it's it's
it i saw the movie it's hysterical
it's it's better than the first one and
there's a lot of big explosions again
it was supposed to come out in august
they pushed it to the following august
which is
next august but i think they're even
getting antsy about that
i wouldn't be surprised if we saw that
movie on a streamer
yeah i actually um i i wonder
because there's so much product that's
sitting waiting to come out
that it can't all come out when theaters
open and what's more
i think you can agree we're both in la i
mean i originally thought that by
may we might be getting back to some
sort of normalcy and now i'm looking at
the calendar and looking at the
vaccine and i'm like oh i don't know
about that no
no no no no my cousin works at kaiser
and
uh he said we you we are so
beyond overload like we're incubating
people in the hallways
like it's he said i know you're living
your life thinking well maybe it's bad
maybe it's not i don't know why is
everybody making a big deal about it
because
we are it's crazy in los angeles it's
it's you know so who knows when the
movie
and even when the vaccines start we
start to be comfortable with it it's
it's available when are we gonna go sit
in movie theaters next to each other i
don't you know i don't know
i you know it's it's a scary i
i don't know how we ever recover
fully from what's going on uh you know
and but i'm not an intelligent guy i
i'm i'm sure people have a plan but i
just don't see it happening anytime soon
no i i agree with you i think yeah
listen that's a whole nother thing
but i am curious when you're making
hitman's wife's bodyguard
when you you obviously watch the first
film you see how much
they're like riffing with each other and
how funny
they are with each other are you sort of
showing up on set knowing
okay i gotta really be able to improvise
in some of these scenes and sort of go
with it
yeah look i i you know i've been doing
it just as long as
anybody else right so i love improvising
and that's fine i
my idea is look they're the funny guys
they're the stars
right there they're why i'm in the movie
and they do this like you know
reynolds does his thing that sarcastic
kind of deadpool
character you know he's quick and and
sam just
says [ __ ] you six thousand times and so
they have this thing
the one who steals it for me is selma i
mean she is
she's a she's amazing and my characters
like
doesn't want to be there he doesn't want
to be there right and he's from boston
and so i barely understand anybody and
so the funny
the funny thing that comes from my
character is the straight
is playing it straight i'm playing it
angry and straight and you know
i just want to get the [ __ ] out of here
and and that in itself becomes funny
you know that and and so it's you could
you kind of have to
you know i'm a supporting character i'm
not going to come in there and and
i don't want to come in and go hey i
want to pop
you just gotta come in and serve it you
gotta serve the other characters and
serve the piece
and if you do your job well people will
attach themselves to you
they'll like your character too you know
and so we'll i saw the movie and i was
like
i look terrible i was i was i was
drinking too much wine in croatia
but i think i think i pulled it off and
i think it uh the character fits in well
with the
with the other guys you worked with
james monaco on the purge movie
yeah uh and then you you i guess you
worked on
with him again on once upon a time in
staten island well i did two purge
movies with him and then once upon a
time in staten island which
is a complete 180 degree
departure from it's a real it's an
amazing film it's another film that got
caught
up with covet i can't wait for people to
see this movie
what can you say about it because
obviously this is uh
i guess it must be autobiographical for
him
you know i i think part of it is and
then he
it's a family drama surrounded by this
idea
of staten island where he still lives
and and what rocky the rocky movies
represented
in the 80s to all the people in staten
island the italian and irish americans
right and but it's
what's inside of it is this this broken
little family
that goes on this journey and they each
each one of them
have have this this revelatory change by
the end of the film
and growth and naomi watts this is now
my third movie with her
she's so amazing to me she's the best
actress that i've ever worked with
uh and bobby cannavale is great uh
demonico
people will understand that how talented
this this guy really is
and we are talking him and i
about another purge movie what
yep for sure he reached out to me not
too long ago and
and sebastian not the producer and
they're like what do you think and i'm
like what do you what do you think and
they're like we talk to universal and
they want to see
leo barnes and and you know in the fifth
purge if if we can come up with
something great i said i'm
in i'm i'm doing a heartbeat i was gonna
say i think there's another purge
movie tentatively coming out this summer
yeah
yeah i don't know if it'll hit the
theaters but yeah i mean at this point
who knows
um with are you a bit surprised at
because the purge movies i mean listen
people all these people talk about
making sequels to so many different
movies
you never know what's actually going to
get popular then you have a franchise
like the purge
which is you know they've made what five
movies six movies whatever the number is
what do you think it is about the purge
oh
yeah i mean he hit the button he you
know he connected to the zeitgeist
it's you know what would you do if you
could get away with anything
for 12 hours it's listen it's what would
you do with a million dollars it's one
of those scenarios it's everyone thinks
about it
well if i had a million dollars i would
well if i could kill this guy and get
away with it it would be
i would kill and and so everybody can
relate to it
and it's it's uh you know
it's it's hyper realism the way he cuts
you know the way he shoots it it's
almost cartoonish
it's uh they're fun movies they're just
and people yeah i mean i i'm pr i'm
i think that purge anarchy movie is to
me
one of the coolest like b movies that
i've seen in a long time
and forbes magazine wrote a great
article about the importance of the
purge franchise
and how it relates to what we're going
through in the world
not in our country in the world so i i
you know i think they're i think they're
uh it's an important thing it's an
important franchise and so i
in a minute i would do another one it's
gonna be my i think my last thing which
is obviously you and joe have a
production company war party yeah for
what is coming up with you guys in terms
of what you're looking for
in the future what are you guys
developing
well you know we try not to develop too
much because you get caught up in that
world but you know joe and i are like a
40-year married couple
you know we you know we we get into
arguments and we don't talk to each
other for weeks at a time and
you know because we're so close and then
you know he gets on my nerves i get on
his ears
uh where we were anticipating some good
things happening
once boss level comes out uh and we
he's right now cutting a cop shop so i
leave him alone
and we have uh what's on the plate
immediately
there's two things one is called graves
which is i did a movie called wheel man
for netflix i don't know if you've seen
it
it was a while back um i'm going to get
you in trouble now and say that we did a
premiere of that movie
bro i drink a lot um but it's kind of
like real man only it's a horror movie
it's it takes place in a car it's it's
phenomenal
and then we're we're doing uh a movie
called
xeno which we're trying to put together
with dion taylor who i did black and
blue with
the director uh and we're trying to get
someone like will smith to play
my brother uh adopted brothers and it's
it
it's kind of like it takes place inside
a building
and uh it's kind of like the raid um
but but a little different which one do
you think might go first
i think graves could go right away i
think either one of them could go right
away but graves is a small movie it's
like
eight million bucks so we could do that
quickly and it's it's all interior
so it's also covered friendly uh
so probably that one but you know joe
might be exhausted after he finishes cop
shop and he might need to go away for
four months
you know uh that's the thing about being
a director you know he he wrote the
movie
then he preps the movie then he's got to
make the movie and then he's got to cut
the movie
right so it's for me i make the movie i
go do another movie and then another
movie and
or i stay at home and you know he's got
to continue on his journey
and and make the film uh so he might be
tired
and he might be tired of me too so he
might want to break
i think a lot that's something one of
the things i try to talk about with
filmmakers to sort of educate people
that aren't familiar with
the movie-making process which is when
you're a director and you sign on to do
a movie it's at least a year of your
life
to joe's credit uh he handles it
brilliantly but
you got to deal with a lot of people you
gotta d you're dealing with
every person that's involved in the
filmmaking process from
from i mean from soup to nuts they all
worked for him
he's got to deal with all these people
he's got to fight for the movie
so if the movie needs more money he's
got to go to these you know we have to
go to these financiers and kind of
you know take from peter to give to paul
it's a it's a listen
i wouldn't i don't ever want to direct
ever i enjoy producing i
like putting the puzzle together but
that job i don't i don't
i don't want to do it i don't want to do
it uh i understand
last thing for you so where it's now the
beginning of january
what's your schedule like for the
upcoming few months in terms of what
you're going to do
yeah i'm going i'm going they just
pushed it a week i'm going to do a movie
uh
in mississippi a day to die it's called
uh it's
me and uh hopefully a good bruce willis
uh and then i'm going to do another
movie
in vancouver after that
uh and then
i have one other move there's two movies
that i have offers on i'm gonna decide
which one
i'm good until the end of april
and then joe and i will figure out what
we're going to do oh so you're you're
non-stop again
yeah man like i said did i tell you i
was divorced
right so that comes with that is uh is
two households
so i have to pay for a lot of things so
i'll be working a lot yeah
and i have like seven or eight movies
coming out
no i looked on the always accurate imdb
and it was like
oh he has a lot of stuff coming out yeah
good stuff i have some really good stuff
coming out that i'm excited about that
is very different stuff
uh from it's all different from each
other which i'm
you know uh but most importantly is that
boss levels coming out
i think just for me and joe what we've
gone through i think
hopefully that will kind of reap some
benefits
uh for us as as uh as two guys who just
constantly push rocks up hills
because that's what making a movie is
yeah i mean listen man
i've seen boss level two or three times
and and i have
so much fun with it and i really can't
wait for people to see it because
for people that don't realize it's you
know it's an action groundhog day
and i don't know how you pulled off we
talked about this about
i think you guys made the movie in like
26 days or some crazy six days
yeah crazy number and it's so much
action it doesn't make sense
no we were so dialed in him and i we
were like we're either gonna do this
uh or we're gonna die trying and we went
from 41 days to 27 days
talk about financiers they took away all
those days and we said well we're gonna
do it we hired 280 people we're not
going to put them out of work
we got to do it and he said can you do
it can you do it i said dude
i'll do 20 pages of dialogue a day if
that's what i have to do and i said i'll
do my stunts
if i get hurt we got the guy like we
just did it and it worked
you know hey listen man i really
appreciate your time especially giving
me literally so much time
and um good luck with your new house and
with everything you have going on i
noticed the punching bag also
oh yeah yeah yeah i have a couple of
them hanging around the house